What are you putting in your body?
Dead carcass pain, suffering.
Can I have all of my vegans go into that
pool of light and my non vegans are in
that pool?
First statement,
taste plays a big factor
in my eating choices.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean that's a huge thing for me.
I think it's one of my weaknesses
is actually like butter, salt.
It's one of my weaknesses.
I love food and I think my relationship
with food actually deepened when I
became Vegan. I don't think I
appreciated it as much as I did before.
I was Vegan.
My name is Ari Davis and I have been
vegetarian for 24 years and Vegan for 13
years.
I believe that humans are
the top of the food chain.
It's a human at the same level of
equivalence is like a fish. Right.
This is probably a big reason why I'm
not vegan anymore. Right? Is I didn't,
I couldn't,
I didn't see that.
I had to see myself at our
moral equivalent of a fish
and it gets into moral
questions like,
you know,
why should we have a pet that's
a dog rather than eat the dog?
And I think the most important question
is why should I love my neighbor rather
than eat my neighbor?
My name's Steve Michelle [inaudible].
I was a Vegan for a year.
I was a vegetarian for two years.
I am a mediator now.
I've been so for over five years,
like I don't even see like what is like
a food chain, you know what I'm saying?
That's just some construct some guy made
and put a little diagram and put us the
human beings in the top.
So
I don't think it's a question
of whether we're at the top.
I think it's a question of
what do you do with that?
If you have a more conscious
energy than an animal,
what do you do with that power?
Do you choose to take a life
or do you choose to live in
love?
I put a lot of thought into my meals.
The way I support my body and my
health is extremely important.
I don't find that I can function at
my best either. Healthy, productive,
emotionally stable,
intellectually capable unless I have
a lot of proper nutrients in my diet.
Six years ago I became
Vegan because I got sick.
I started to realize that my health
is directly attached to what I ate.
Since then,
my friends and family have supported me
to feeling better and I'm better than I
was before I got sick. Uh, I don't
really like cook or anything,
so I don't really put too
much thought into what I eat.
I guess I live a fast paced kind of like
I'm working late nights or I'm waking
up early.
Sometimes it's easier
to grab this quick process sandwich
or I wish I planned my meals out more.
I think I would be a lot.
I would feel a lot better.
I think it's will be powerful
no matter what you're eating,
to put your intentions into whether it's
prayer in vocation and it's just such
great power in presence versus
just like scarfing something down.
But like can I just really
be present with this meal,
take my time and chew it slowly.
So that's the first one that I
resonate with and what I choose.
I would kill an animal.
Okay.
I think there'd be tons of context
where I'd kill an animal. Like if a,
if a lion is going to go kill a baby,
I'd probably kill an animal.
I'd kill an animal to save a human life
and I get the vegans probably wouldn't
do that if I could do something to
prevent killing them besides eating them.
Like if I was protecting
myself and we had to,
we had it like a something that we
could do to get that animal away.
I would definitely try to not kill it.
I mean,
I feel like it comes down to you or
the animal. You're killing the animal.
I would,
I would.
They're going to give up
their life for the fish.
Why is it always the case when talking
about what I kill an animal like exactly
what you were in a client's wandering
around downtown La when I was in the
hiking. There's, there's mountain
lions are coming kit and kill people.
You've known that, right? That's
an orange county, but that's not,
that's not in the jungle in Africa.
Did you kill an animal? It's an orange
county. Mountain lions have killed hikers.
Kids. What'd you just let them
know? We'll let the guest die.
We're hiking in the mountains
and there's a mountain lion.
I have to be aware of the fact that I'm
in mountain lion territory and be like,
I'm okay with the risk because to be
honest, I'm not hiking with a gun.
I have no way to defend my friend. Yeah,
you don't hike with Nike, Paul? I've been,
I don't call against a mountain lion.
I don't think your wedding, I just,
I just want to say like even if I
did and even if my attempt were to be
successful, I would feel awful.
Having killed the mountain lion.
What were your feelings or your just
foundation then for your beliefs then?
100% or if human beings,
animals. Yes, yes, sure.
Would you kill another human being
to save another human being? Yes.
What makes one person more
valid as a student to another?
Is it your relationship to
that person? It would, yeah.
It would probably be so if for example,
I raise an animal in the wild,
it's like an animal I've
built a relationship with
and that animal now threatens
the life of a human being, but I don't
know, but I have no man. It's entire life.
What makes killing that
animal as just cause. Okay.
As opposed to saving that life.
I have a,
I have a longer relationship
with that animal.
Why would I kill the animal
before I'd save that person?
Like it's about relationship.
You killed him.
A person over an animal because I
believe human beings are animals.
NASA humans at a different level,
but maybe a bell.
He fish at the same level as a person.
Hey, we see it very different. I do.
It costs more than it should eat healthy.
It's more expensive to eat healthy.
I don't think it's too expensive.
Farmer's market is something that
I'm trying to frequent more. Oh.
But sometimes you know,
you can go spend $20 here and
definitely not get as much.
Um, I definitely want
to see that, you know,
maybe that'll encourage people to eat a
little healthier if you can go grab that
fresh fruit, fresh veggies
for five, 10 bucks, you know,
I think,
uh,
our culture as a society is just in
grade towards like the fast food culture.
It was just cheap and accessible.
But now I think we have more of a
established like medical basis on what's
healthy and what's not healthy.
And to get that content and to
have it be tasty as well is,
is expensive.
I'm running it. I have so much to say.
It does not cost more money to be Vegan.
That is a myth. It takes planning.
Yes. The convenience is last.
Can you grab a hamburger at
Mcdonald's for sure for 99 cents,
but k how much lentils can you buy?
The issue is capitalism.
Like that is what is
keeping us where we are.
It's not that humans are smarter and
they're going to come up with this
technology. The technology
exists. It is there.
We can feed so many people.
It is capitalism and factory farming
and most of these companies that are
selling us products that are like shitty
food, they don't give a fuck
about you at all period.
Someone sitting on the island somewhere.
Oh yeah,
like just stacking bread and
then Paul this fast foods,
she eating really healthy food
and they probably even real good.
Yeah,
they're not eating any of that shit.
You go to certain neighborhoods, certain
areas you don't see the same fast food.
You don't see the same restaurant
and it's all for a reason. Yeah,
no stability. I mean, yeah, that's a
good point. It's like they don't have,
why is there many health food
stores in the hood? I come,
I can't like get an option wise is
liquor store anywhere and it's true.
It's like you have to,
when you break it down there's like
malicious intent to d harmonize and like
lower the vibration of certain people
and certain areas and it's like that's a
part of it too. It's like,
what am I contributing to?
Sure. I'll say this. You know,
when I was 11 years old, my father
passed away from his second heart attack.
He was diabetic.
He was pissing out of a two by watching
him deteriorate my youngest years of my
life for like years and years,
just a tear rate,
taking pharmaceutical drugs and just
kind of basically dying slowly because of
what he chose to eight to me, I'd rather
spend an extra dollar. I need her again,
nick or something.
Helping now and live longer.
Then try to cut corners when you know
in the end twice now instead of later. In
the end, my mom was same thing. She died.
She was eating buckets of ice
cream when she passed away.
She died at 49 years old.
Wow.
Now choose no,
the more education now we can put out
there. Just like stuff like is beautiful.
That's what I was most anxious about is
learning more of what I'm trying to step
into.
I don't know if I'll ever give up chicken.
I'm just going to be honest with you.
I don't know.
I want to eat a lot cleaner chicken.
Do you guys have like cheat days ever?
Hell No.
I am Vegan 100% at the front line.
Ethical reasons, always, always, always.
And that's why I don't think in
24 years I've ever fought back.
It was hard to try new things.
Things I didn't like,
found a tons of feed and
food. I was like, Oh God,
what the fuck are you people eat it.
And then simultaneously realizing
that there was options. You know,
there's always choices and it's always
choices you make. Like you said,
you may never give up me um,
fully,
but it's like you're making a choice to
or at least thinking for yourself and
making a decision.
Then like that's all you can ask
people to do is think for themselves.
Really appreciate each and every one
of you all. Thank you. No problem.
Thank you.
No, thank you for coming
out. Nice to meet you ladies.
What's up guys? I have a Mari and I
am Jason. And am I a question for you?
You have a question for me.
What do you like about middle ground?
What I like about middle ground is seeing
people come together and like realize
that their labels are not the whole,
some of their very experienced,
like take it off,
take it off the labels,
realizing there's so much more than
their labels. That's right. I love that.
All right,
well tell us in the comments below why
you love middle ground and if you've been
a label they want to take off and throw
on the ground, tell us that as well. Uh,
we love you guys. As
always, please subscribe.
Hit that like button and
I'll see you next time.